[Applause]
pilot to Bombardier pilot the bomb
before Kadir baby it's one spell you
dare enter this house [ __ ]
hello is it me you're looking for I
don't
uncle Jolyon in the Garden of Good and
Evil
getting ready head out the [ __ ]
Portland Oregon it's a beautiful day to
be alive still [ __ ] up from last night
we're like 1500 milligrams we did close
to [ __ ] 32 bong hits it's over you
understand me I woke up I did sushi
gotta take a nap I worked out how to go
talk to some people by the dog but you
know what that's all over we're here and
with queer concept it was sparking we're
doing a recount you know how to recount
all my [ __ ] bowls today all this
recount shit's got me all paranoid stuff
but it's a beautiful afternoon to see
you guys say hello maybe do a little
chit chat a little meet-and-greet a
little tight as they say and will flop
and smoke a bomb we move on you know I'm
sorry I [ __ ] you're doing people to see
I do we show it to calm you stood man
it's like a private function for
Christmas so some Jewish League you know
me I love [ __ ] Jews I'm gonna sizzle
those [ __ ] still dealing the
[ __ ] dictator questions I don't give
a [ __ ] you know it's it's he's dead but
I don't give a [ __ ] and that's it's
gonna be a great weekend up important
Felicia Michaels come up with me the
podcast is in you got your two podcasts
for the week they were both [ __ ]
phenomenal and that's it I can't ask you
for anything else don't forget a week
from tomorrow my special comes out see
so TV at CES all TV the code is Joey you
get two months for free it's usually
four bucks of giving you eight dollars
for free who does that for Christmas was
last time somebody gave you eight bucks
got seven anyway I'm smoking this brain
freeze [ __ ] the fact is fun
Kozma anyway wave would have a good time
oh [ __ ] think you're dealing that's it
people you got what you got a 24 maybe
25 more days to [ __ ] Christmas so get
your [ __ ] together you know here comes
Santa Claus here comes Santa Claus done
Santa Claus Lane
well that shit's companies I'm saying I
haven't heard John Lennon yet so I'm not
depressed once you hear John Lennon it's
time to shoplift [ __ ] that means things
are better all over and so this is
Christmas and what have you done undo
[ __ ] this year I did some showers I had
a good time I smoked some refined it's
amenable Ridley and you move on
oh nice when we get together like this
in the afternoon and get combed up it's
now people don't get toned up by day you
stay and I've got so much drama to get
tuned up may I get tuned up 10 15 times
a day nobody knows nothing you're gonna
get tuned up you got to do it in a hurry
get your head together get focused and
do your back biting the [ __ ]
the neck my track
as do a bowl is [ __ ] not mine and
then we'll let you go I know you got
[ __ ] to doing people to see lotion
running home right now maybe your home
you're [ __ ] trying to poison your
kids I don't I don't I don't ask
questions damn you know makes my morning
I put it when I roll a [ __ ] bowl when
I roll the number I fill up a bowl and
the weeds beautiful it does something to
my heart right here I'm saying it's like
saying a puppy anyway I hope you guys
are great I hope you've been listening
to the podcast hoping and getting your
life together 2017 is right around the
corner [ __ ] I'm in the same boat as
you I'm 53 I'm [ __ ] lost I gotta
write goals I got a right [ __ ] hey we're
in this [ __ ] together ain't
nobody perfect here we pull our pants on
one leg at a time
that's all right here getting wound up
getting focused for the last half of the
day
I just blew me out of the [ __ ] arena
that it right there
for Portland to get the go fast got
something tomorrow night Friday and
Saturday two shows don't come crying to
me on Friday Joey the tickets what am I
gonna do the weekends gonna go before
[ __ ] Thursday
Thursday's light it's Friday Saturday a
[ __ ] almost gone I mean the place
only seats 20 75 people in Hanover 240
your [ __ ] shows he may get you [ __ ]
together but you know what Thursday's a
good night I get there I hear breakfast
tomorrow
do a little radio get [ __ ] stoned all
day maybe do a little workout and we go
down at 8 o'clock we'd like that place
on fire jack helium dad good [ __ ]
food dude I got a Cuban sandwich with
potato tots you know I ain't [ __ ]
around so I advise you right now get
your tickets this don't come hit me up
front you kill me what are we gonna do
we're gonna do we plan this my daughter
I told you to [ __ ] wasted I'll get
him enough with the tape Taipei in the
tickets let's smoke some [ __ ] really
you see some smoke about layers did you
see it I'm coming up on fire
I get smoke coming out my ass and get my
own show on Vice balls smoke we just
wanna [ __ ] the smoke things out he is
but that's it and that's that you got a
big week you know we had a good game
people but he learned we're alive
nobody's Isis ain't [ __ ] us in the
ass and we still can make a choice all
right so stop your [ __ ] crying who
gives a [ __ ] guys do it to me again
I can't hang out with you people no more
because every time I team up with you
guys I end up here and [ __ ] people
yelling in Russian online people bad
influences you like hey I love you but
you know what we're not you
[ __ ] and have you got so I need
you people we got to keep doing this
every day
little Tecate is good for the [ __ ]
hand of hanging out deal with [ __ ]
you know I'm a shop and Mick will do one
later when he gets it with a suit on
we'll do it [ __ ] we'll do a little
[ __ ] periscope of you guys you know I
love you and forget about you
Portland's gonna [ __ ] around those
tickets are gonna go next Thursday see
so called do right now go to see so
tv.com put your name email confirm and
put in Joey and get two months for free
and next days that we'll all watch it
together from the [ __ ] office you
know I love you guys I got something
planned for next Thursday so stay black
we'll be back